So this week we're gonna be talking about
the subject of tissue engineering and
it's covered directly in chapter 14,
but not in a lot of detail.
And so I provided a couple
of other readings which um,
um, are listed here on this slide.
And these are in the, in the, uh,
in the lecture notes. If you go to
that folder, there's two papers,
one from 1993 and one from 2002.
And so I would read them in that order,
read the one from 1993 and then the one
from 2002 and you'll see sort of how
this field,
which I'm going to describe today has
evolved over the last 15 years or so.
And,
uh,
some of the challenges that were talked
about in this article from 1993 you'll
see are still present today is
turned out to be more difficult than,
uh, than biomedical engineers thought
to accomplish some of these things.
And some of the things have gone faster.
We've made more progress than
we thought we would in 1993.
So if you read those two papers,
read the the bit from chapter 14 about,
um,
about tissue engineering.
And then chapter 16.
I've also given you chapter 16 is about
bio materials and artificial organs,
but there might be some things in there
which are useful to you in, um, in uh,
understanding, uh, this subject as well.
And a section we'll meet this Thursday
in the regular time and place.
So, um, so what's the motivation for, uh,
for tissue engineering and, um, this, uh,
slide has a lot of numbers on it and the
particular numbers are not important.
I've posted it in the notes for the
course so you can look at it, uh,
at your, at your leisure. But the, uh,
the main point here is that there are
many diseases that drugs cannot treat
effectively and their
diseases that are prevalent,
they don't occur in small numbers.
And that's why all the numbers are here.
So you can see how many incidences
there are of these different, uh,
of these different, uh, what
is labeled on this slide,
organ and tissue deficiencies.
For example, you know,
that a burns of the skin are quite common
and some burns are not severe enough
that they need any other treatment other
than maybe some antibiotic Lotion and
addressing while it heals. And
some burns are so, uh, so, uh,
severe or so extensive that they,
uh,
that they threaten the life of the
patient who has them. Uh, if you lose,
if you lose a nef of your skin,
uh,
you lose a lot of water
through that open area of skin,
you can become dehydrated, uh, to the
point where you can die of dehydration.
And so your skin is an important barrier
for keeping water inside your body.
And of course, your skin is a barrier for
keeping other things outside the body.
Toxins and in particular microorganisms,
viruses and bacteria.
And so your risk of infection is
tremendous if you have large burns over a
significant part of your body.
And there's no way to, uh,
that we currently know to speed up the
healing of skin fast enough that patients
that have severe skin skin
burns can survive that injury.
So what's done is that you
need a skin transplants,
right?
You need an preferably an autograft of
skin taking skin from one place in your
body and putting it into another,
right?
But if you have severe burns
over much of your body,
then there's no skin to graft,
right?
So you might take an aloe graft,
autograft is a graft from you,
from the individual to the individual
taking some of your tissue and moving them
to another location.
That's auto self graft.
Aloe graft is from a similar individual,
but not you.
Somebody who might be matched but not
perfectly matched immunologically to you.
And you get a graft from them.
So when you get a blood transfusion
from somebody that's not you,
but there's some matching that's gone
on to make sure that you're not going to
be incompatible with the blood.
That's an aloe graft. Xeno graft.
Zino x e n o is a graft between species.
So that would be a graph from
another species to too human,
for example, or between species.
So autograft, allograft, xenograft,
good words to know for our
discussion on tissue engineering. Um,
but you can imagine there's a limited
number of aloe grafts that his skin
transplants that are available
to treat a burns. And so,
and so not all the patients that need them
are able to get these kinds of graphs.
And so, uh, so life is threatened
in that situation. Not only burns,
but there are pressure sores.
What are commonly known as bed sores for
patients that have to spend significant
time in, uh, in a bed because of,
because of an accident.
Let's say they've had a spinal cord injury
and they have to spend a lot of time,
uh, recovering, uh, from that or
they can't move anymore on their own.
And they'll develop sores, which
are very difficult to heal. Um,
and diabetics, uh, because they, um,
because diabetes can affect,
uh,
the sensory nerves in your
extremities, uh, often get,
uh, sores in their extremities,
particularly in their feet or lower leg,
which don't heal very well,
partly because they can't
feel them as well anymore.
And so they become injured
and continue to get injured.
And partly because the process of
diabetes slows down healing in general.
These, they get ulcers or lesions
on their skin that don't heal.
And um, so just this top
category alone, lots of patients,
different indications,
not enough tissue to treat these
tissue deficiencies of the skin.
If you went down this list, you
would find, uh, many others as well.
So let me go down here.
We're going to talk about in some
detail the liver and when you get liver
disease,
that's severe enough.
The only medical option right
now is a liver transplant.
And we'll talk about why that's
the only option available for, uh,
for liver disease that
becomes very severe,
that could result from
some metabolic disorder,
from cirrhosis or from liver
cancer. Uh, but in that case, uh,
transplant is the only, it's
the only option. And, uh,
I'm sure you've all heard in the news
about cases where there is a patient,
often a child who has some, a disease
waiting for a transplant and calls,
we'll go out to the community.
Um, and uh, um, and uh,
this is a familiar,
a story in our society.
And the reason for that is because there
are a significant number of patients
that are in this category.
Not as many as in the case of skin,
but a significant number.
And there is something
like tens of thousands of
patients that are eligible for
liver transplants and waiting for them.
And why are they waiting?
Because there's not enough donor organs
to satisfy the need of people that have
transplants.
And um,
and that's unlikely to change,
right? For a, uh, for a liver
transplant donor to become available.
Somebody has to die with a healthy liver.
They have to have consented to have
their organs used for another person,
and they have to be match immunologically
with a patient who's going to receive
the donor. And somehow those two
things have to come together,
right? And so all these
things have to work right?
In order for a liver donor
and a recipient to match,
they have to match not only biologically,
but it all has to match in
terms of timing as well.
And that's a complicated process.
So today if you go and look on
this, uh, on this website we've set,
we meaning we as a society have set up
organizations and procedures to try to
help with this matching process.
And so one of those is called the organ
procurement and transplantation network.
They keep track of all the patients that
are on lists waiting for organ organ.
They keep track of all the organs
that are going to come available and a
matching process occurs and you know,
and,
and computers are involved in all kinds
of the resources you would expect to be
involved in this thing. But if you look
for any particular kidney transplants,
there are currently, as
of yesterday, 75,000, uh,
individuals in the u us waiting
for, uh, waiting for a donor.
Kidneys in the liver there are 16,000.
So these are patients that today need a,
uh, uh, an organ donation there.
Physicians have decided that they're
too sick to respond to any other,
uh, treatment and they're just
waiting for an organ to appear.
We, I talked at the, in the very
first lecture you might remember,
I showed you this picture to talk about.
There's already very high
technology involved with this, uh,
with this medical effort.
And part of the technology are things
like this organ procurement network.
So this is,
you know,
run electronically on the Internet
using all of the high tech tools of
communication that we have in order to
connect physicians who are trying to
treat patients with physicians who find
that there's a donor available and by,
uh,
by other high tech industries like the
airlines who can quickly move Oregon's
from one place to another.
So if the donor of the Oregon died in
California and the recipient is here in
new haven, then you've got to get the
Oregon as quickly as possible from, uh,
from California to Connecticut and um,
and that that can be
done. Now sometimes. Um,
another technology which is embedded
in this is that some hours have to pass
right between when the organ is harvested
and the organ can be transplanted.
And so you need to be able to preserve
organs for that period however long that
period is and you'd like to be able to
preserve them for a long period of time.
What if we could preserve donor kidneys
in the same way that we preserve blood?
So blood you,
many of you have gone when the,
when the Red Cross has has come
here looking for blood donations,
they take your blood,
they store it in a special way such that
it can be used up to three weeks past
the point when you donate it and that
creates many opportunities for your blood
to be useful in the same way if you
donated organs and there were ways to
preserve the organs, that would
be make them more useful as well.
And so there's that whole technology
behind this that I wanted to at least
describe to you in words.
And you could think about biomedical
engineers are currently working around the
world on better ways to preserve organs,
but it's a difficult problem,
can be accomplished in blood and certain
kinds of blood cells can be partially
accomplished with some tissues like skin
cannot really be done with livers or
kidneys at yet.
But there's a great need for that.
Um, why I wanted to say a little bit
more about why you have to take this
extraordinary measure of transplant,
uh,
to treat diseases like liver failure.
Uh,
when a liver becomes so
diseased that it cannot,
um, than it cannot recover
its function on its own. Uh,
lots of things go wrong.
And this chart is a table of some of the
functions which are happening every day
in your liver.
And the liver is an
important endocrine organ.
We talked about the endocrine system.
It makes hormones like IGF one,
it activates a vitamin D,
which functions as a hormone is an
important for structure of your bones.
It produces the hormones that are used
in your thyroid gland and many other
hormones. And so if your liver
starts to die, you start to lose.
The ability to produce those hormones.
And you can imagine then that lots of
things in your endocrine system start to
go wrong. The liver also produces
many of the clotting factors.
These are proteins that are
needed for clotting blood.
If you have an injury and
if the liver starts to die,
you're not making as many of these.
You can have a bleeding disorder.
It makes plasma proteins like albumin,
which have many functions in the body.
It makes bile acids and bile acids are
very important as an excretory organ for
getting rid of molecules that the kidney
is not able to eliminate into urine.
And I could go on down the list.
I put it here just to say that when
your kidneys, when your liver fails, uh,
thousands of things start to go wrong.
And you could imagine treating any
one of these with drugs, right? If,
uh, if you know the problem is, uh,
is activation of vitamin D,
You could take vitamin D,
You could take pre activated vitamin D.
If it was a thyroid hormone,
you could take a thyroid hormone, right?
If it was any one of these things,
there might be a medical solution for it,
but when it's this whole list of things
because your whole Oregon is failing,
you can't support that
function with drugs alone.
It's just too many things
going wrong at once.
So drug therapies are usually used for
treating something where we understand
what the molecule is involved is and
where there's only one or two molecules
that are involved, you know, so
it's some metabolic disorder.
You're not making a particular molecule
that you need and so you take it in the
form of a pill or you have
an enzyme that's not working
properly and so you take
injections of that enzyme.
Or in the case of cancer,
there's a single drug which can
eliminate the unwanted cells in cancer,
right? These are areas where
drug therapy works. Gene therapy,
which we talked about a little bit, works
in other kinds of situations, right?
Where you're missing an element of a
cellular process like insisting fibrosis,
for example,
your lungs and other tissues are missing
a membrane protein that's important and
transport of chloride
across your lung epithelium.
Now you can't just take that protein
because it won't get inserted into the
cells in the right way.
We talked about membranes and how
proteins are inserted in membranes and you
can't just give the patient that membrane
protein and have it restored to the
right location in the cell.
But because it's only one
thing that's going wrong,
you can think about treating this with
gene therapy by giving those cells that
are missing the protein,
a gene that allows them to produce that
protein on their own and to correctly
inserted into the membrane.
So gene therapy as possible to think
about in diseases like cystic fibrosis and
some diseases of the liver and other
organs as well. But in general,
there are diseases that are
caused by a single gene defect.
When we're thinking about liver failing,
lots of things are going wrong.
Many genes involved,
right?
And so gene therapy isn't really thinkable
in that situation where the whole
Oregon is starting to fail.
And so whole organ transplantation
is the only, is the only, um,
current solution, a
surgical solution for, uh,
for problems like heart failure,
kidney failure, liver failure,
where the whole Oregon
is starting to fail.
The motivation then for tissue engineering
is to try to think about another way
to treat these diseases where you would
somehow manufacture or create a tissue
in the laboratory that could substitute
for the transplanted tissue from another
patient.
All right?
So the idea is to try to make synthetic
or semisynthetic tissues that could take
over the function of a failing liver,
a failing kidney failing blood vessel,
a failing heart,
right?
And it is intended to treat these diseases
that are too complex to think about,
complex in the number of
things that are going wrong.
Too Complex to treat with any of the other
therapies we've talked about over the
course of the, uh, of our time here.
So this is a field that
was really, um, um,
has ancient roots and those ancient
ruins are discussed in your,
in your book.
But the idea of engineering tissues was
only developed relatively recently and,
uh,
first defined really in the 1980s.
And so that first paper I gave you
to read by Langer in Vacanti, um,
is a really considered one of the first
most influential scientific papers in
this, uh, in this growing field.
And here's one definition of
what tissue engineering is.
I told you what the goals of
it are kind of in broad terms,
but it's the application of principles
and methods of engineering and life
sciences toward fundamental
understanding of structure, function,
relationships in normal and
pathologic mammalian tissues.
That's not the more interesting part to
me. The more interesting part to me is,
and the development of
biological substitutes to
restore main tain or improve
tissue function.
So why is it only in the 1980s that
people started thinking about this?
And there's really two reasons and one
is an engineering reason abroad reason.
And the other is a sort of life
science and biology. Reason, uh,
that we had come to the point in the
1980s were a lot of the biology that we've
talked about now was fairly well known
in particular the the biology of cells in
culture of taking cells
out of organs and tissues,
maintaining them in culture,
getting them to do the things we wanted
to do in culture was fairly well known
by the 1980s.
It's a fairly mature technology.
And so one could think about using
cell culture techniques to produce
complicated structures. And the
other is an engineering, uh,
in engineering, uh, advance.
And that is that we had developed by the,
uh,
by the 1980s enough understanding of
artificial bio materials that we could
start to create materials
that had unique properties,
which made them good candidates for use
and the kinds of applications I'll talk
about.
So the innovations or the,
or the kind of foundations
of tissue engineering, our,
our ability to culture cells and to do
that reliably reproducibly to understand
what cells are going to do when we
maintain them outside the body and our
ability to build materials
that are biocompatible,
that can be implanted into people and
that can serve as scaffolds for a new
tissue.
And I'll say more about what that means.
So just to try to put this
in more concrete terms,
here's two examples of
how you might artificially
engineer a tissue or two kinds
of applications that people might
think about in a heart that's failing.
And I use this as example because we know
a lot about the cardiovascular system
now. And so you'll understand both of
these examples we talked about. Uh,
we talked about the important function
of the blood vessels of the heart,
the coronary arteries,
and we also talked a little bit
about how these vessels become,
can become diseased in, uh,
in life, uh, particularly, uh,
for, um, for patients in the sixth
or seventh decade of their life.
And so th this vessel might
become diseased through a
process of atherosclerosis.
The lumen becomes narrowed such
that blood no longer flows,
the resistance gets too
high for blood to flow well.
So you'd like to replace this artery and
the only thing that the artery has to
do is carry blood from one place to the
other. So really all you need is a tube.
All right.
And so people have tried for years to
use different kinds of tubes to replace
this section. The operations
called a cardiac bypass, right?
And so a surgeon will go in, he will
remove this disease section of tissue,
or he'll just put a,
a bypass around it.
That is a tube that goes from this
location and connects to this location.
So like a bypass on the highway,
it's a clear route that allows you to
get around a route that's no longer
passable.
Well,
these vessels carry a lot of blood and
they have to be very reliable vessels
because they need to carry blood all the
time because your heart is constantly
working. It needs a constant,
reliable source of blood.
And so the best substitute
for this is a natural one.
And so one of the most
successful operations here is
to take a blood vessel from
somewhere else in the patient's
body and use it to create a bypass,
right? And, and you'd
like it to be an artery.
And so bypasses can be made.
There's another artery that's nearby
called the internal mammary artery that
that surgeons could take. You can take it
from the tissue sort of near the heart.
It doesn't really serve as important to
function and you can bypass it in here.
And now you have a new artery in place
to, uh, to continue to flow blood.
That works. But what if you have
more than one site of blockage?
What if you have a blockage here and a
blockage here and a blockage over here
and a blockage over here.
So you need multiple bypasses.
You don't have enough
arteries in order to do that.
So then the surgeon will go and take the
saphenous vein from your leg. It's a,
it's a large vein in your leg that returns
blood that's flowed down to your leg
back up to the Vena Cava,
and there are enough other veins in your
leg that you can lose that vein without
any loss of function in your leg.
They can now take the vein and cut it
up into segments and use that to bypass
all these segments of
artery that are clogged.
And that works as well. But veins aren't
the same as arteries. You remember that?
And if you take a vein which
has a different anatomical
structure and put it in
the position of an artery that is exposed
to the high pressures that you know
already occur there,
sometimes that works,
sometimes the vessel changes and remodels
and adapts so that it functions and
sometimes it doesn't.
And sometimes those veins also become
diseased and they no longer serve as an
effective bypass, right? So
then what do you do? Right?
If both of those options fail,
you can try to use synthetic materials
and synthetic materials are used to
replace blood vessels in in many
parts of the body. If you're,
if you have an aorta that has an aneurysm,
a surgeon can put a synthetic piece of
basically dacron a synthetic material and
it will serve as a functional
aorta and do a very nice job.
But it turns out that we know from
experience now that that only works if the
vessel is big enough
because for big vessels,
all of these kinds of synthetic
materials that we make,
while they might have the right mechanical
properties to serve as an aorta,
they're not biological.
And so blood will clot when it
hits that unnatural surface.
And it's okay if blood clots on the
surface of a big artery because it's big
enough that you could have a lining
of a clot here along the inside,
right.
And it would still be enough diameter
to flow if it's a small artery and it
clots blood doesn't
pass through any longer.
And we know now that the limit of what
one can do with synthetic materials is
about half a millimeter to a millimeter.
And that's the size of
these coronary arteries.
So you can't use
synthetic materials there.
So what we'd like to do is grow
and artery outside the body.
Okay?
What if we could do that by taking the
synthetic material and growing on it?
Aligning of natural cells.
Okay.
The synthetic material would provide
the mechanical properties needed,
so for it to function as an artery and
if we grow natural arterial endothelial
cells all over the surface of this,
the blood wouldn't know that
it's a synthetic material.
It would only see the cells which
are forming the natural barrier,
the natural wall of a blood vessel.
So that's tissue engineering and example
of tissue engineering to create an
artificial artery to use in bypass.
And I'm going to talk more
about the details of where
we are in that process and
what the obstacles are. Next, on Thursday,
let's say you didn't get there
in time in a particular patient,
they didn't have a bypass in time.
So they have a blockage,
they have a myocardial infarction or a
heart attack because the blood becomes
compromised to some area.
This area of the heart doesn't
get blood for some period of time.
And so this tissue in the
wall of the heart dies.
Now in general, uh, if that happens, uh,
there's only a limited ability of your
heart tissue to heal after you have a
heart attack.
A scar is formed here and this part of
the heart doesn't function in the same
way that it did before.
Remember how it functions is it has to,
it has to transmit electrical signals
and it has to contract in response to
those electrical signals. And it has
to do that with a regular frequency.
So it has to both conduct the electrical
signal and contract. And this, uh,
this, uh, damaged cardiac muscle
doesn't do that anymore. Well,
sometimes that's okay.
You might not need all of your cardiac
muscle to be functioning in order to have
a reasonably efficient heartbeat.
But sometimes the area of this is so
large that it compromises the ability of
your heart to deliver the cardiac
output. You need to stay alive. Right.
Uh, so what if you could make
an artificial cardiac muscle,
right?
What if you could take some kind of a
material and grow cardiac muscle cells on
it and grow them in such a way
that they filled up this material
and they started to function like heart.
That is they,
they functioned in the right electrical
way and they functioned in the right
mechanical way.
Then maybe a physician could come in and
just so this patch that you've created
outside the body into place on the tissue
and maybe that patch would start to
function like that part of the heart wall.
That didn't function.
Okay.
Okay. Now where would the cells
come from that you did that with?
We think about this particular
application. We're going to create a,
we're going to create a patch for
repairing a myocardial defects.
Right. Where would the cells come
from? What would be your first choice?
Okay.
Of cells that you wanted,
that you use for this
jasmine
from the heart.
From what heart?
Yeah,
from the patient's own heart.
What if you could take a small biopsy of
tissue from somewhere else in the heart?
You could take a small sample of those
cells and you could take them outside the
and grow them in culture.
Well,
this is where our ability to culture
cells comes in very handy because we can
take a small sample,
isolate the cells we want,
propagate them in culture until
we had millions of those cells,
put them into the patch, put the
patch back into the patient. Now,
now the patient has an auto graft of cells
but placed in the right configuration
so that they function as a tissue.
What are the problems with that?
What's the problem with that?
Okay,
so if the, if the disease was
too big, you couldn't do that.
Why couldn't you do that? Because you
couldn't grow and upsells you think or
yeah mate. So you might, there might be
some practical limits to it, but you're,
you're getting close to what the
real problem with that would be.
You're getting close to what the
Think about the timing of it.
How long would it take you to take this
biopsy and grow the cells and make a new
Ar? Artificial? Probably
would take weeks to do.
And could the patient survive those
weeks while you're making the, uh,
the, uh, the, the, the tissue
engineered solution? Maybe,
maybe not. It would depend on
how extensive the, the, the, um,
the failure of the heart was
as, as, as Justin described.
Right? So what would be
another solution to that? Well,
let's not take cells from the patient,
but let's create a bank of heart cells.
Right?
And that might be possible,
but you have to be able
to preserve heart cells.
You have to have a bank of cells with
all the right immunological markers
labeled.
You have to have them in enough quantity
that they'd be available rapidly.
And so there's problems with that, right?
But maybe you could do it that way.
Maybe you could use stem cells
and we talked about stem cells before
and some of their capabilities.
But one of the real advantages of what
people think of as using stem cells to
treat diseases in adults is just
exactly what we're talking about here.
Being able to create an environment or
an engineering solution in which stem
cells could be used to
create functional tissue,
right?
In this case,
you'd want stem cells that could very
quickly become cardiac muscle cells that
could be differentiated in
the cardiac muscle cells,
and ideally you'd want stem cells
from the same person, right?
You'd like to isolate them
from the same person somehow.
Okay.
Or from a or from a
donor that was matched,
but you're starting to see both
the opportunity, I hope and the,
and the problems that have to be solved
and creating these new solutions.
I list on this slide a few
of the characteristics of
a tissue engineering that
we're going to talk about. Uh,
not in quite this organized a way,
but I hope that by the end of the week,
you'll be able to look back
at this list and say, Oh,
I understand what that characteristic
means in terms of what we're trying to
accomplish in tissue engineering.
The first is what I've been
talking up about up to this point,
the tissue engineering really represents
kind of a modern or contemporary
logical extension of conventional
medical. And surgical practices, right?
If we're going to make an
engineered tissue, in many cases,
we're going to give them to a surgeon and
they're going to do what they know how
to do, which is replace an
organ or a tissue, right?
So you're just giving another resource
to surgeons to do what they know how to
do already.
And we're using it to extend medical
practices to diseases that cannot be
treated by drugs or gene therapy
or other kinds of medicine.
What I want to talk about,
uh,
for most of the rest of the time today
is this second bullet here that tissue
engineering and vaults control
or regulation of normal
healing processes that if
we want to understand and
use tissue engineering,
we need to know something about how the
body heals itself and take advantage of
those natural mechanisms
of tissue regeneration.
And we'll talk over the course of the
next two lectures about tissue engineering
as a,
as an attempt to replace the
sailor component of disease
tissues where it's drug
therapy.
We're thinking about the molecular
component and now we're replacing cells,
um, that it uses cellular processes
sometimes to control drug delivery.
We'll talk about how you could use tissue
engineering as a drug delivery system
and that a tissue engineering produces
new models for the study of human
physiology. I won't say anything
more about that this week.
So let me just say that now that what
if you could produce heart tissue like
this for transplantation?
Another use for it would be if I can
make this tissue outside the body that
behaves like the human heart,
I can use it to study how the human heart
works outside the body in a much more
reliable way or a much more sophisticated
way than I could with ordinary cell
cultures. Because now you not
only have the cells of the heart,
but you have the cells of
the heart arranged in the
right kind of configuration.
So I could understand, I could use it
to understand how the heart develops.
I could,
I could expose it to different drugs
and ask what are the toxicities of these
drugs to the normal heart without
doing it in patients, without,
and with doing it in a system where I
have a lot of control and a lot of ability
to look inside and see what's
happening. All right. Um,
so let me go back to this point.
Now.
Tissue engineering involves control or
regulation of the normal healing process
and we're all familiar with at least some
aspects of healing because you've all
had a cut in the skin,
uh,
that has maybe caused you some distress
in the short term. Maybe it was a,
a cut that was deep enough and this
shows you the structure of the skin.
Here's the outer layer
of the skin here that um,
that forms this sort
of thick barrier layer,
the epidermis that things can't
penetrate water can't penetrate easily.
You put water on top of your skin.
It, it beads up there, right?
It doesn't get absorbed. Likewise,
water inside doesn't come out.
That's why you don't get dehydrated and
micro organisms can't go through, right?
Because of this barrier underneath is a,
is a more connective tissue layer called
the dermis. And inside this Dermis,
there's cells that are producing an
extra cellular matrix of Collagen.
Largely. We talked about extracellular
matrices several weeks ago.
And within that, and within
that a collagenous matrix,
there are blood vessels,
arteries, red here, veins blue,
and those blood vessels bring
blood to the skin to provide,
uh, um, oxygen and to get rid of
carbon dioxide in these cells,
in your living skin.
So you get a cut in this tissue.
And what happens if it's a
deep enough cut? You Bleed and,
uh, you gotta do something
to stop the bleeding, right?
You've had this and so you,
you put some pressure on and you wait
for clotting to occur, but you've,
but you've disrupted these vessels,
right?
You'd disrupted these vessels.
They have clotted so that the clot is
formed inside these vessels so that the
bleeding stops and usually a clot forms
at the surface. And if you look at this,
after you've got the bleeding to
stop, you have a red looking, uh,
you have a red looking area, right?
It looks different from your skin.
That's the beginning of the healing
process is that your body has coagulated
blood at that site to replace
the tissue that's been lost,
right? So you'll have a red, uh,
you'll have a red spot there that turns
into a reddish looking scab, right?
That's your body responding
to stop the immediate insult,
the bleeding and to fill up the space
of this tissue that's been damaged.
Cuts too big.
This can't happen.
You can't just put pressure on it
and stop it. And so what do you do?
You go to the emergency room,
you get some stitches,
they bring the sides of that
wound back together with stitches.
They hold it closed and the
same thing happens, but in
a smaller space now, right?
Cause they've just brought the tissue
together so that your body could produce
this,
uh,
this provisional tissue
and the provisional tissue
at the beginning is just a
blood clot.
After that point,
many things start happening
within the skin. Uh, and uh,
a complex process of cells sending out
signals and cells responding to signals
in a coordinated unregulated way occurs.
And what this diagram shows is some little
fingers of tissue entering into this
coagulated provisional matrix
that was formed by the blood clot.
And these cells are initially
cells that are called fibroblasts,
which live in the dermis.
And normally they're just sitting there,
sort of an acquirer,
essence state,
not reproducing very rapidly
making college in providing
matrix to keep up sort
of the normal structure of your skin.
But when there's an injury,
they get turned on and they
migrate into the wound.
They migrate into this provisional
matrix and they start changing it.
They start digesting the clot
and they start making new,
extra cellular matrix of Collagen.
And they do that so that there can be
a pathway for these blood vessels to
regrow the blood vessels need to regrow
renourish the skin so that you can start
to get the normal composition back,
the normal cellular components.
And you'll see these blood vessels,
uh,
starting to form sprouts that enter into
this provisional matrix all now you've
watched the process of a scar
healing on your own, um, body,
and you've seen the stages that it
goes through. It will, it will, uh,
go from the red appearance to a,
to a dollar red and eventually
become a white, you know, or, uh,
it doesn't look red at all.
And after some period of time you won't
even see where the cut was it all right.
The end process of this
fiber blasts coming in,
replacing remodeling the matrix of blood
vessels regrowing back in establishing
new cells from the epidermis start to
grow in over this matrix in the end first
they'll grow over the top.
And so you might see a little bump here
and eventually the whole tissue through
this elegant self regulated
process heals itself.
So you can't see where the cut was.
We've all had that experience and probably
we've also had the experience where
we got a worst cut, right? And,
and it didn't end up looking right,
right.
You might still have a scar from
some cut that you got on, uh,
on your hand or your arm where
the, where it was too severe. Now,
what happened there?
The same process of remodeling happened,
but it happened in a more aggressive or
more vigorous way because the signals
that control this, we're
large. It was a large wound,
big problem. Lots of sales got
activated, they made a lot of Collagen.
They may, they remodeled this, this
provisional matrix very aggressively. Why?
So that you could heal and so that you
wouldn't have a wound here that was open
to infections or loss of
blood or loss of water.
Your body knows how to respond to very
severe injuries are more severe than we
usually encounter in our lives and the
result is you'll get a scar from that
because the response was too aggressive.
Right?
Our ancestors who lived much
more dangerous lives than we did,
who might get attacked by a lion or a
bear needed to have a very aggressive
healing response so they didn't
die if they got attacked.
Under some circumstances,
we don't get attacked by lions or
bears so often anymore and so we don't
necessarily need that
aggressive a healing response.
We might like a gentler healing response
that leads to a better functional,
okay, that doesn't have
a scar, for example.
So how can you control
healing in that case? Well,
uh,
one of the ideas of tissue engineering
is to provide materials that would guide
or regulate or change that
natural response of healing.
So you have a wound and the wound is
going to heal on its own in some way,
but you would like it to heal in a way
that you control so that the outcome is
more to your liking. Now maybe the
outcome is that it heals much faster.
Maybe the outcome is that
it heals without a scar.
Maybe the outcome is that it heals
and new kinds of cells are, are, are,
are woven into the tissue in place
of the ones that were there formerly.
All right,
so maybe this wound was created by a
surgeon who removed the cancer here and
you're trying to replace the cancer
cells with normal cells. All right,
so what are the options in terms
of doing this? Well, what is it?
You could put the material in here and uh,
and the material goes into the wound
and that material has some function and
maybe that it serves as a
better provisional matrix,
then the clot would have and better means
what maybe it regulates how cells grow
in or how cells attach or how cells
synthesize Collagen after they enter.
So maybe you could design a material that
changes the healing response locally.
That's, that's one of the, that's one
way that you might engineer a tissue.
Now here,
I haven't put any cell cultures in.
I've just put in a fancy material
that I designed. All right,
we'll talk about what those
might be a little bit later.
Or maybe you don't need a material at all,
but maybe you could
replace this with cells.
So maybe I could just take cells may be
recovered or harvested from some other
place in the patient.
Maybe these are skin cells that I got
from a normal location and I put them back
into a wound in order to speed up the
process of healing at that site. Right?
Maybe their stem cells that came from
somewhere, but maybe they're just cells.
But oftentimes the best combination
seems to be to put cells in together with
some material.
And here the material might function
in a couple of different ways.
It might function in this way we talked
about here by giving signals to the
normal tissue to regulate the healing
response that's going to occur anyhow.
And that,
and that material might contain cells
that you have derived somehow that you
want to hold in that site.
You want to hold locally and provide an
environment where they can grow and take
over the function of the tissue,
right?
So these are some sort of schematic ways
to think about how one might use tissue
engineering to control the normal
healing process. And I've shown this,
I've given you examples of this, that, uh,
where I motivated it with
thinking about the skin,
but this doesn't have to be the skin,
right? This could be a your liver.
Maybe I put the material into your
liver, uh, that allows it to regenerate.
Maybe I'd put liver cells derived from
some other source back into the liver.
And they take over the
function of the liver.
Maybe I put materials on cells and
create a new liver tissue, right?
So you could extend this idea
to almost any tissue or organ.
Here's an example of that.
And, and um, where, uh,
just a material is used to, uh,
to guide the healing process. And,
and I think this is conceptually a very
simple idea and one that that works to
some extent.
So this is a nerve and so proximal
means closer to the brain.
So maybe this is a nerve in your leg and
it's got severed by some kind of injury
or it got crushed and somehow the
nerve is damaged in this region here.
So this nerve is sending sensory
signals from the distal part,
backup the nerve into the brain.
It's sending motor signals down from
the brain to the more distal regions.
If this tissue, if this nerve
gets damaged by trauma somehow,
um, then you're not going to get
sensory signals sent through it.
You're not going to get motor signals.
So you can't feel,
you can't move in all of the tissue
that's distiller downstream of that.
Um, of that site. So how do you,
how would you repair that? Well,
it turns out that surgeons know that if
it's a small region and they go back in
and they take the damaged ends of the
nerves and they put them back together,
you will recover much of the function
of that nerve. Maybe not 100%,
but if they do it quickly
and they do it well,
that these cells will regrow
the connections that are
lost in this section of
trauma and you will over a period of time
begin to feel in that tissue again and
you'll be able to, to move, right. If the,
if the damage is too big,
you can't physically bring
them back together. Right?
Your leg is a fixed length and if
at the DC area damage is too big,
you can't bring these
tissues back together.
They found that you can use an autograft
that is take a nerve from somewhere
else.
If I cut the nerve out of another spot
and then put it in this region in between
the two ends,
the nerves will regrow again.
Problem with that is you don't have a
lot of nerves that you're not using.
And so in order to repair this nerve,
you had to sacrifice a
nerve somewhere else.
So maybe you could do that
same thing with the material.
So what would the material look like?
The material might look like this,
and this is just a cylindrical
cuff and it's a complete cylinder.
It's shown as a cutout here
just so that you can see inside,
but it's a complete cylinder that's hollow
and you put one end of the nerve into
one end and one of the
nerve and the other,
and now you've placed these
nerves not in physical contact,
but you've created a compartment
through which they can communicate.
So you don't have this end of
the nerve dangling out in space.
And this end of the nerve dangling
out in space. And remember,
it's not going to be a nice picture like
this where the nerve is existing on its
own,
but there's muscles and blood vessels
and other kinds of things around in this
area.
Right?
And by putting a channel
with the nerve in both ends,
you've isolated the area of the nerve.
You want to regenerate from
all the rest of the tissue.
Does that make sense? And you hope that
you get some regrowth through here.
And what, uh, what scientists have
found that is it, that you do this,
you will get some regrowth. You don't
get complete regrowth of a thick nerve,
but you get a thin nerve with less fibers,
less nerve tissue,
less function, but you get
some recovery. So it works.
And we've known for about 20
years or so that it works,
but it doesn't work well enough. So
how could I make it better? Well,
one way you could make it better
is by changing the material.
Maybe the properties of
the material weren't right.
Maybe the cuff on the outside
is to impermeable and you'd
like to have molecules
exchanging in some way, right? Maybe
it's not permeable enough, right?
And so you need to regulate it that way.
But maybe you don't want a nerve cuff
that's filled with just air or just water.
But maybe you'd like,
uh,
maybe you'd like a nerve conduit that's
filled with a material that promotes the
growth and reconnection of these fibers.
Maybe you'd like some kind of a gel
in there that nerves could regenerate
through.
And so the obvious place to go for that
is to use the kinds of materials that
the body uses for repairing
tissues and fill up this channel,
not just with water or sailing
or some kind of a solution,
but fill it up with an extra cellular
matrix like the kind of extra cellular
matrix we talked about weeks ago,
that all of your tissues have the
supporting Gel likes structure formed from
proteins and carbohydrates that are
secreted by cells and through which cells
normally grow and live.
And so taking natural proteins like
collagen forming gels out of them and
putting these gels inside the material
increases the number of fibers that crow
across a gap like that.
So this is just an example
of a simple example.
No sales involved here of a material
that's designed in order to enhance the
healing of a wound and how one might
engineer properties of that material.
To make it better at supporting
the healing function.
So that's what I wanted to say about
tissue engineering, tissue engineering,
and vaults control, or regulation
of the normal healing process.
But I want you to keep that
in mind as we go through. Uh,
the examples that we'll talk about
in, uh, Thursdays, uh, lecture.
I'm going to stop there, uh, questions.
See you on Thursday.